belle tradizioni sono famiglia e oggi
siamo su un altro fottutissimo gioco con
la colò straits ormai ragazzi o perdiamo
in tela lo ho la fobia di questo coso
comunque a parte tutto regala gioco che
sto per fare non è esattamente giochi
che faccio di soli c'è vedrete voi
stessi lasciamo perdere
vi auguro buona visione tenetevi forte
ma veramente forte dario che trasmettono
ok ragazzi che figo praticamente adesso
che sto per fare non è un gioco e una
un'animazione dissi ma che cos'è sta
roba ragazzi il veto gesù è il dolce è
andato via gesù allora ecco che arriva
gesù ci sei sono qua fu lì c'è scritto
culi non era gesù giorno amico amico mio
che cosa cazzo stai facendo
forse sta cosa ma veramente salve
che cosa [ __ ] dovrete saremo tipo un
cartone però va visto con l'occhio alla
verona figata estate pensa che sia
questo perché così
se mi fido ok amico mio togli la mano
degli ti prego
qualcuno ha voglia di spiegarmi questa
cosa va bene sei rimasto sorpreso amico
mio vergognosi contento
no no no ma come per cento ragazzi va
perché qual è il senso di questo genere
cosa ridete non perche no quelle otto
ragazzi due premi nobel
direi è una cosa incredibile fantastici
posso parlare anch'io così e marche
cassani che mangiatori per spa riuscire
a fare cose cioè anno non sono esplosi
che i ragazzi mi spiegate il senso di
questo già bello comunque finora il
significativo ma è una tipa questo nome
sono maschio e femmina si capisce hanno
solo fatto vedere i culi fishing flusso
che bello problemi della coppia tutti no
va bene che cosa cuccio logicissima
solletico sto morendo di diabete che
cazzo è ragazzi dove devo guardare
buccia di sopra c'è un culo alla lunga
questa
che cosa cazzo appena visto legamenti e
meno ragazzi questo era cool in gioco e
si chiama culi non vedevo l'ora di
provarlo giuro direi di passare al
prossimo tempo più serio si spera
nell'effetto ragazzi ci siamo allora
control cos'è ai menu questo bellissimo
in italia non funziona come non detto
funziona bombay cos'è ex co so bell
cazzo sono super mario ragazzi ha
praticamente dovrebbe essere il gioco di
shining
se qualcuno ha visto il film non l'ho
visto perché mi pagavo troppo addosso a
cosa posso andare avanti
vado senza pedalare ovviamente a slitta
proprio bello contro la porta bellissimi
non lo adoro già sto gioco posso far
manovra ma ragazzi una fisica che è
spaventosa c'è l'incredibile e io vado
indietro su ca farmamica armi fate
capire un attimo come giro c
i ragazzi ci sono dei suoni bruttissimi
si può entrare nelle porte ma dovevo
andare di qua per fare vado di qui
qualcuno mi deve spiegare com'è
possibile che vada avanti sto coso senza
una pedana con le frecce pedala senza
freccia non pedala voglio capire il
senso ok ragazzi va bene non importa che
ho sempre sognato di essere su un
triciclo giuro
devo capire anche dove stornandole mi fa
impressione però dico sul serio comunque
non ho mai visto supermario su un
triciclo o lo dico ragazzi comunque va
bene così che cazzo di hotel e questo
pironi curve giorno salva gen gemelle
olsen se poi volete vedere il mio bel
tris lo zio fratello posso avvicinarmi
senza che mi stupri a te la mamma nome
poi tornerei volentieri dietro dietro
dietro dietro si ma va troppo veloce so
cosa un po di enfasi
salve ma che belle facce che avete mai
sentito parlare di mascara no sono
bloccato ragazzi arrivo arrivo subito un
grande show altri tre cicli se volete
stavo scherzando ragazza è scappata
conti ragazzi ragazzi
via di qui in via di qui via di guida di
chi pedala soprattutto per faccia che
cazzo
e che la uccise di precisione
i ragazzi mi perdo non voglio vedere se
c'è un infarto ok ance che porta sud
ero terrorizzato dall inferno veramente
è stato assurdo next one perfetto
ragazzi questo si chiama un amico
porca [ __ ] via via via via via viene da
me
oggi sono incastrato vero state
buongiorno game over
sono un fenomeno astigiani bello mi è
piaciuta sua esperienza incredibile
game over plessi skype di no voglio
continua voglio voglia di farlo perché
sono bravo mesi fa ci riprovo ragazzi
perché sta attorno a cui si può cambiare
picchiati amico ma facendo c'è come
cazzo ma via via via via via via marzo
bello ho già preso un tronco ragazzi su
bmi non c'ho la patente potrebbe essere
un problema
ma vi sta proseguendo
che cazzo via via via via perche ho
preso un tronco va bene ragazzi io non
ho capito facessi giochi comino farmi
dare prima al triciclo e poi una chat
digitpa caso
buono fino calzature le crocette non lo
vuole le corti height ragazzi non è un
ardente c'è ma perché mi sta seguendo un
t rex cioè che cosa cazzo fatto rubato
del cibo in scatola domande basta io
ragazzi non potete farmi fare giochi
come il vino perché non amare no no eh
sì bello che sei bello lo sapevo anch'io
prima allora lì che a figo ha detto
perché non ho capito un cazzo al pad
rivelare prima
il padre perfetto c'è un t rex
che mi stordisce leggermente le orecchie
ma probabilmente tentando di strada armi
le mutande non ho capito perché io sto
guidando una cosa ma di macchina io non
saprei guidare una strada vuota aperta
praticamente devo guidare con dei
tronchi e con un po tutto ci resti in
erba touch sua madre che quella mai
veramente brutto a tua madre ti giuro ma
che poi l'ha visto gioco che se vado
indietro con la testa non vedo più un
cazzo perché ci sta roba
ecco infatti i propri nutro fi faccia
giusto bello lo ha fatto proprio bene
senti stronzo ma c'è un regola cos'è sta
roba
niente e poi sbatto contro qualcosa che
non esiste
non so guidare ok non so se si è capito
che io perché cristo ma non è capitato
qualcosa cazzo faccio di sbagliato e
mezz'ora che ci prova a far sostanza non
ci riesco a poiché per lavori avviare
ogni [ __ ] volta il coso perché sennò
non funziona più il loculo una merda da
adesso in avanti record mondiale non me
ne frega niente stata ci provo ma mi
ricordo neanche indietro partito fosso
perchè io posso e non ho capito il senso
di questo gioco ragazzi
un'ansia della madonna che probabilmente
stanotte bisogno di rex che mi vorranno
nelle orecchie perché il ex google hanno
ragazzo
volevo fargli ero però il rischio di
sbattere allora basta bis o rotti i
[ __ ] basta mi sono rotto i [ __ ]
ma veramente non è indecente cosa cosa
ciò al posto dei capelli legati cioè in
tre giochi non ho fatto uno decente
va bene concluso qui l'episodio faccio è
che questa è la valigia la sto facendo
perché ovviamente dopo aver provato
stand erden devo correre in bangladesh
quindi ragazzi se il video è piaciuto ma
senza stato momento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e come livido trattando
iscrizione solo se lo vorresti ti
screditano fosse unito belle ragazze